[Música]
y comenzamos en este día de hoy revista
de prensa ya está lista conmigo en el
estudio rosa pérez masdéu rosa feliz
mañana del jueves vamos a abrir entonces
con la última entrega de lo que ocurre
en reino unido- políticamente hablamos
bueno entre otras cosas del par y gates
una imagen publicada en exclusiva por
the mirrow que muestra a boris johnson
una reunión con alcohol esto en las
navidades del año 2020 en plena pandemia
en pleno confinamiento la instantánea
podría entonces implicar no en la lista
e interrogado en el marco de esta
investigación rosa que lleva a cabo la
policía metropolitana buenos días raúl
exactamente y en este sentido titulan
tanto de mirror como the times estos
medios que hemos seleccionado y es que
bien como comentabas esta instantánea
que parece más bien ahora cuando la
veamos aquí una captura de pantalla pues
él remueve las cosas en esta
investigación que ya se llama operación
hillmán y si bien este hecho no que se
trata de una web virtual que tuvo lugar
el 15 de diciembre de 2020 no estaba
siendo investigado en profundidad por la
policía metropolitana ahora y han
avisado las autoridades que van a
revisar el estatuto de esta pieza de la
investigación y que boris johnson se
convertiría en una de las más de 50
personas que recibirán a finales de esta
semana un interrogatorio vía email para
responder a sus implicaciones en este
escándalo llamado party gate y mientras
boris johnson intenta digamos desviar la
atención mediática en temas como la
crisis de ucrania o pues el fin de las
restricciones en el reino unido-
distintos parlamentarios aseguran que
tarde o temprano el primer ministro
británico va a acabar cayendo sin
embargo desde downing street- aseguran
que aunque llegue a ser multado boris
johnson no va a renunciar y sólo para
terminar con este primer tema the
gardian señala que miembros del partido
laborista
piden una investigación a la policía por
otro tema sino por un
supuesto hecho de corrupción en la
renovación de la residencia del primer
ministro y su mujer en downing street
rosa cambiamos de tema pero seguimos eso
sí con un líder bajo el escrutinio bajo
la lupa hablamos del presidente de
brasilia y bolsonaro como titula carta
capital dice lo siguiente el tribunal de
la haya recibió el informe de la cpi de
brasil rosa efectivamente desde ayer la
corte penal internacional ya cuenta con
este informe que redactó una comisión
parlamentaria de brasil que investigó
exactamente como el gobierno de
bolsonaro gestiono la pandemia y en este
texto pues se acusa tanto al presidente
de brasil como a otros miembros de su
gobierno de distintos crímenes algunos
tipificados en el código penal de brasil
otros supondrían crímenes contra la
humanidad como
persecución recordemos particularmente
tanto más bien por omisión que por
acción en lo que fue la protección de
las personas indígenas durante la
pandemia en brasil vamos a ver cómo
evoluciona todo este caso en la corte
penal internacional y continuamos en
nuestra región rosa y es que las
palabras del presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador sobre el boat voy a
citarlo pausar la relación entre méxico
y españa retumba una prensa mexicana
pero no solo era mexicana sino por
supuesto también en la española rosa así
es vamos a fijarnos en distintos
titulares empezamos por la revista
proceso de méxico que dice amlo plantea
poner en pausa las relaciones
diplomáticas con españa no queremos que
nos roben y destaca pues palabras del
presidente mexicano durante tres
sexenios empresas españolas como
iberdrola repsol o hl fueron
beneficiadas por los ex presidentes
vicente fox felipe calderón y enrique
peña nieto- con contratos millonarios
que significaron un saqueo para mexico y
que estas empresas se sentían dueñas del
país por otro lado el universal titula
senadores de morena respaldan la
intención de ambos de pausar las
relaciones con españa pero que el
gobierno ha aclarado que no se trata de
una retirada de diplomáticos unidad ni
de embajadas sino más bien de un
statement político y finalmente pues el
país
titula con las polémicas de lópez
obrador con españa del pida perdón al
rey a mí no me paga repsol y es que
recordemos que en 2019 ya el presidente
de mexico mandó una carta al rey de
españa felipe sexto
o que pidiera perdón por los crímenes
que se cometieron durante la
colonización española de américa algo
que la casa real nunca llegó a responder
y por otro lado el país nos da un dato y
es que españa es la segunda fuente de
inversión de inversión extranjera
directa en méxico después de eeuu con
más de 70 mil millones de dólares y
cerramos en eeuu rosa con una polémica
acerca imagínense usted de la quema de
libros de harry potter entre otros esta
quema fue promovida por el pastor
evangélico en tenis y el mismo estado
que fue noticia también en un distrito
escolar que previó la novela gráfica
mouse que trataba el tema del holocausto
rosa exactamente esta quema de libros
tuvo lugar el pasado 2 de febrero en
nashville y como comentaba se quemaron
objetos tanto relacionados con harry
potter como crepúsculo como disney
porque por esta iglesia la consideraban
pues objetos y novelas pues malditas
pero lo interesante de esto raúl es que
el pastor que promovió esta quema de
libros greg loc agradeció a través de
twitter que los medios de comunicación
satán y hayan hecho tanta repercusión de
esta quema porque dijo que así ayudaron
a que otras personas conocieran sus
actividades esto nos hace plantear un
poco qué papel tenemos en la
reproducción de ciertos discursos los
medios de comunicación y sólo para
terminar raúl hemos querido ver que el
'washington post' tiene una columna de
katrina band el joven en la que dice que
si bien cuando pensamos en censuras de
libros pues la imagen que nos viene a la
cabeza son la que más como está sin
embargo las censuras que tienen lugar de
forma recurrente en eeuu son en
reuniones de padres en distritos
escolares como ha sucedido recientemente
con la prohibición de esta novela
gráfica mouse también en un distrito de
text rosa gracias entonces por toda la
información la revista de prensa de hoy
nos vemos mañana con más de nuestra
sección y de pasar a hablar de fuego
pasamos a hablar del agua de nuestros
océanos de esto con este primer invitado
del día